NICK ORLOVE: Good morning,
and good afternoon
to everyone kind of in
the global audience.
Welcome to the
GCP Online Meetup.
My name is Nick Orlove.
I am one of the Google Cloud
customer engineers based out
of the Bay Area.
And today we have a
super awesome talk
that we're jazzed about, talking
about the hidden costs of Cloud
with one of our
customers, Server Density.
But first, Yuri, you want
to introduce yourself real
quick for anyone who's new.
YURI: Sure.
Hi, folks.
Really happy to be
here as Nick's co-host.
My name is Yuri.
I am another customer engineer.
And we're coming to you today
from the music practice studio
here at YouTube, which
is always a fun time.
Unfortunately, I don't have
any opening riffs for you.
So I'm sorry for that.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah,
well, it'd be much worse
if I had any opening riffs.
I can't play anything.
So you guys are fortunate.
Cool.
And we also have David Mytton.
David, you're with
Server Density.
You are the CEO and co-founder.
Do you want to introduce
yourself real quick?
DAVID MYTTON:
Yeah, that's right.
So I'm David.
I founded and built
the original version
of Server Density in 2009.
And it is a software as a
service performance monitoring
product.
NICK ORLOVE: Awesome.
So just out of
curiosity, software
as a service monitoring
products can be very broad,
as can Cloud.
So would you mind taking
maybe a couple minutes
and explain what it is
that you guys monitor today
and how you're helping some
customers, whether they
be Cloud or on premise,
and your overall solution.
DAVID MYTTON: Sure.
So Server Density is
primarily an agent
based monitoring
product, which means
that we have a small
piece of software, which
you install onto your servers.
We're completely agnostic
about where it might be,
although nowadays
most of our customers
are running in the Cloud.
But the agent runs, it
collects core system stats
and sends it back to us
so that we can show graphs
and we can trigger alerts and
manage your infrastructure.
NICK ORLOVE: Awesome.
There's a little
bit of a feedback.
Do we have a mute
on that, by chance?
YURI: We do.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
Cool.
Well, when we switch
back and forth,
we might have to
worry about that.
But awesome.
So David, I really want
to thank you for the time.
You are based out of the UK, so
thank you for joining at 5:00
PM your time.
And this is pretty
awesome because this
is going to be our first
international meet up,
where we're talking across
the pond, I guess as they say.
But really, the reason
why we reached out
to you and the reason why
we want to have this meetup
is you wrote a
phenomenal blog that's
called "The Hidden Costs
of Cloud" that's on Medium.
After this, we'll post a link
to it so that everyone can read.
But I was really
hoping that we could
spend some time talking
about your experience,
not only just migrating
to Google Cloud,
but hopefully an unbiased
conversation about what kind
of hidden costs you might be
referring to, how you tackled
those, and then kind
of how you better
architect for planning
the overall TCO
and the overall cost of Cloud.
So does that sound
good to jump into?
DAVID MYTTON: Yeah.
Excellent.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
Cool.
So maybe first we could talk
about what it is you migrated.
So I know that you
performed this migration,
I think it was either
late 2016 or early 2017.
So maybe you could walk us
through your environment
that you had to migrate,
some of the challenges
that you encountered, and how
the overall experience went.
DAVID MYTTON: Sure.
So there's two key problems that
have been keeping us working
hard on the technical challenges
over the last eight years
or so.
And the first of those is
processing large volumes
of incoming data in near as
close as possible to real time
so that we can trigger
alerts for customers.
And then the second
problem is the storage
of large volumes of
time series data.
And that's what powers the
graphs for our customers.
So the two use cases
obviously getting
notified when
something is broken.
But once you've got
that notification,
you need to be able to
see what's going on.
And so the graphs are
pretty important to any kind
of monitoring product.
Over the years we've
scaled [INAUDIBLE]
been using the product.
And having a stable
and high performance
time series database has
been a big challenge for us.
And we've also had the challenge
that at the time that we were
scaling there was
no real product that
could solve the different
scaling challenges,
either as an open
source product that we
would have to run ourselves
or as a managed service.
And so through the years
we've built our own things
internally.
And then as services
have become available,
we've looked at how
we can replace them
with something that's managed
for us, because we're just
a small team of engineers.
So this brought us, at the
end of 2016 or in 2016,
where we were having problems
with our existing time series
database.
And we'd built a custom
version, a custom
system on top of MongoDB.
And it's a very good
general purpose database
and has over the years and has
scaled with us, with problems,
but problems that we've
been able to solve.
But we found that we were
spending a lot of time building
custom code.
So time series databases is
a very specialist application
and we built our own custom
version on top of Mongo.
And so we had to maintain
that and build new features
and keep it running,
but also scaling
the hardware side of things.
And we were hosted
on bare metal servers
and also across a
virtualized environment.
And we were spending
a lot of money
and a lot of time
managing what had
to be some pretty hefty
servers, a lot of SSD storage,
a lot of RAM.
And we got to the point where
we were spending so much time--
and also cache on
the hardware itself--
that we decided to evaluate
the options of replacing
the custom built time
series database with either
a product or a managed service.
So we looked at as many
different options as we could.
We looked at products
from Amazon and Redshift
and also RDS.
We also looked at open source.
So Cassandra, MySQL, building
another custom version
on top of that, as many
companies have done,
rewriting it in the latest
version of Mongo DB.
Or, as we came to use, we also
looked at Google Cloud Big
Table, which was very early
on, but was looking promising,
particularly because it
had an official connector
for OpenTSDB, which is an open
source time series database.
That's what the name is.
And that meant that we could
offload a lot of the custom
feature development to
an open source product,
so building things
like aggregating data,
mathematical functions,
dealing with retention
of data, that was all part
of the standard feature
set of OpenTSDB.
And then the management
of the actual data
store behind the
scenes, and that
could be handled by
Google as a Cloud service,
because we could just
connect the two together.
And so our migration
over to Google Cloud
started with a single
service, OpenTSDB,
on top of Google
Cloud Big Table,
as the most expensive
and most time consuming
service that we had to run.
And then as we completed
that migration,
that went live in just over a
year ago, February last year.
And having successfully
migrated that running
across two different
Cloud environments,
we then decided that we would
migrate our full workload over
to Google Cloud, using
Container Engine, Compute
Engine, and a couple other
different other products, as
well.
So that's a quick run through
of the migration story.
NICK ORLOVE: No, that's
really interesting.
And I feel like you're
coming from a position
that a lot of our
customers are trying
to grapple with is they have
some custom built applications
that are running on premise
that they really see some
of the value in,
and that might be
their competitive
differentiation.
But then they also
have some kind
of more generic
applications that
really could be run anywhere.
And they're trying to identify,
hey, do we do a lift and shift
or do we try to rewrite
some of our applications?
And I know that a
lot of our customers
try to grapple with that.
But it sounds like you
found a really good medium
of identifying your strengths,
Server Density's strengths,
as well as Google's
strengths, and then
just being able to kind of
move over what you could
and then optimize
everything else in terms
of making it Cloud native
before moving it over.
So since you've already
kind of crossed this bridge,
and since I'm sure
some of our viewers
are trying to debate if
they are ready for that
crossing themselves,
how about any surprises
that you've encountered.
And let's keep it unbiased,
maybe positive surprises
but then also maybe
some negative surprises
that you wish you had known
before you did the move.
DAVID MYTTON: Yeah, absolutely.
So I think the one that I
focused in on my blog post
is the cost side of things.
I think that's
really interesting.
Because people often made the
comparison between co-location,
buying their own
hardware, and actually
physically racking it,
through to very, very
cheap dedicated servers, all
the way to Cloud environments.
And they're comparable in a way.
But really, it's not completely
appropriate to compare
like for like.
They're not the
same kind of thing.
In most cases, if you're
just comparing CPU and memory
in the Cloud to what
you could buy hardware,
the Cloud is always going
to be more expensive.
You don't really
get the cost savings
just on the pure dollar
value of the resources
that you're buying.
The savings that you get
are in the efficiencies
of moving a core
workload to the Cloud
so that you no longer
have to manage it.
And this comes down to one
of the huge advantages of Big
Table, in particular, in
that we can get scalability
and we know that
it's going to cost us
a very specific amount of money,
and it's completely linear.
And we can do that the click of
a button in the Cloud console
or through the API.
And that makes
the predictability
and the management
very, very easy.
Just comparing to
hardware is very difficult
to do because all of the
added benefits that you get
are quite difficult
to calculate.
So the cost of your team,
the software updates,
the management behind the
scenes, the cost side of things
can be difficult.
But with that caveat and that
you can't really compare them
directly, there are some
interesting features
of the Cloud which are
certainly worth highlighting.
And in particular, it's
that granularity of cost
that you get.
So when you buy a
dedicated server,
or if you buy a physical
server and rack it yourself,
you know that it's probably
just going to be a single cost.
There's going to be the
monthly fee that you're
paying for that server
or the one-time fee
that you pay for the hardware
itself plus the rack itself.
In the Cloud, absolutely
everything that you use,
every single resource
is billed individually
at precisely the amount
that you're paying for.
And this seems like
an obvious thing.
But it is a shift in
thinking when you're
used to just buying
a server and paying
a fixed amount every month,
regardless of the usage
and whether you're
maxing out the server
or whether you're not.
Whereas in the Cloud,
you're actually
paying precisely for
the amount of resources
that you are using.
And this can be quite
difficult to predict.
And there are a
number of instances
where you can get
sudden spikes of usage
that you just weren't expecting.
So for example,
if you're looking
at your current performance,
so buying storage,
for example, and
with Cloud disks
you're often a buying certain
number of IOPS, the operations.
And it's actually
quite difficult
to measure your
current performance
to predict exactly how
your workload is going
to migrate over from physical
spinning disks or SSDs
over to IOPS in the Cloud.
And it's off of that
IOPS number is often
linked to the storage volume
size, at least on Google Cloud,
but also the number of CPUs.
And that is unusual when you are
just buying a dedicated server.
We might not even know
the number of IOPs
that you're purchasing.
You just know that with an
SSD, it's going to be fast.
And that has the side
effect of some time
you're oversizing
your instances,
because you might not
need the number of CPUs
that you're buying.
And you might not need the full
volume size that you're buying,
but you need to buy a
certain number of IOPs.
So that's one of the, I
suppose, the downsides
in the pros and cons of that.
NICK ORLOVE: That's
really interesting.
So I like how you called out
these unexpected costs, things
that you didn't
really anticipate.
So you mentioned the
over provisioning
and how to accurately monitor or
identify how much of a resource
you actually require.
But I'm actually
sharing my screen.
Let me just jump over
into your blog post.
YURI: You have to hit the
Present button, I think, first.
NICK ORLOVE: Oh.
Actually, I did.
YURI: OK.
Great.
NICK ORLOVE: So
one of the things
that I wanted to call out was
kind of the networking cost.
So you mentioned that everything
in the Cloud is billed
and it's billed precisely,
which makes sense.
But in your blog
post, you mentioned
that there was a period of time
where all of the sudden you
saw a huge spike in traffic
exiting your network, which
ended up costing you
some additional funds
through Google.
And what I like is
that you and Google
were able to work together and
identify that it was fraud,
at the end of the day.
However, would you
mind taking a second
and just explaining your
process of identifying that
and how you were able to
work with Google on getting
that resolved?
DAVID MYTTON: Yeah.
So that's a really
interesting example,
because it's a good example of
abuse or an unexpected spike.
And you either got
it as actual abuse
that someone is
misusing your service
or it's a spike of traffic
because you are suddenly,
unexpectedly popular
on Reddit or on Twitter
or something like that.
And there are similar use
cases, although probably
the second one is the
one you want, as opposed
to the abuse use case.
So in this instance, we had
a large spike in traffic
to a Firebase
website that we host
in Firebase just as
a static site, so
at the serverdensity.com
website itself.
And we have a number
of budget alerts set up
on the different projects
within Google Cloud.
So we know what
our expected budget
is going to be for a month.
And we have alerts set up so
that as we're reaching it,
the percentage usage should
basically match how far along
we are in the month.
So 15th of January, thereabout,
should be 50% usage.
And so we have this sudden
spike and our alerts
triggered saying that we'd used
much more of the monthly budget
than we'd been expecting.
And digging into
the usage graphs,
we saw that massive
spike that you showed,
which is basically the baseline.
Our usage of the
website was completely
at the bottom of the
axis on the graph,
so we couldn't even
see our actual usage
because that massive
spike went all the way up.
And so, that was simply a case
of opening a ticket with Google
Support and saying, this looks
like an unusual traffic spike,
not least because it
spiked for a couple of days
and then went back down again.
And working with Google
Support get into the logs.
It was very, very simple.
They just simply said, this
looks like abusive traffic
and we're going to
credit you for it.
And so I think just actually
raising the issues first
with Google makes sense to do,
but having the budget alerts
and the data and the
monitoring is important
so you can spot these problems.
NICK ORLOVE: That actually
absolutely make sense.
And so you mentioned
keeping an eye
on the budgeting and monitoring
of your existing resources.
Would you mind talking
for a second about what
you're using to do that?
DAVID MYTTON: Sure.
So just out of the box,
there are budget alerts
available on Google Cloud.
And you can set this up
based on dollar amounts
and also comparisons
to your previous bill.
So you can get alerts sent
out at different stages
throughout the month.
And of course, the
unlimited flexibility
is kind of the whole
point of the Cloud.
But it does mean that you can
have denial of service attacks
on your credit card
now, as opposed to just
your application.
So it's really
important to do that.
Because as far as
Google is concerned
this is just your application
running and it's not something
that's necessarily proactively
monitored by Google.
And you may end up hitting
your credit card limits
and having a problem at
the end of the month.
So it's important that
you do keep an eye on it.
So those budget
alerts are important.
But you can also get the
usage data dumped into CSV
and also exported into Google's
BigQuery product, which
is a great way to run analysis
on the raw data, what's
actually happening.
So you can analyze that
data obviously by yourself.
You can just pass the CSVs
or query BigQuery, even.
You can also use the
Data Studio product,
which is free as part of either
the G Suites or Google Cloud,
as part of the Google tools,
which does a decent job.
But unfortunately,
it doesn't support
the discounts that are
available on Compute Engine.
So we found the
automatic sustained usage
discounts and the
committed usage discounts
don't get plotted correctly.
And so we're using a
third party tool now
called reOptimize, which
basically queries BigQuery
and visualizes the data for you.
So we can keep an eye
on a almost real time--
it's not quite real time data--
but it's updated within a couple
of hours, up to 24 hours later.
So we can keep an eye
on everything that's
happening in our account.
We can drill down into projects.
We can drill down
into the products.
And you can also label the
resources on the Google side,
so you can categorize and
group all the different things
that you're using and then
build reports based on that.
NICK ORLOVE: Interesting.
Yeah, that makes sense.
So in your blog post, you
also called out the need
to search for discounts.
So you mentioned your customer
usage or committed usage
and sustained usage discounts.
But would you mind
just kind of walking
through what those are
and what kind of discounts
that you really look for?
DAVID MYTTON: Sure.
So the sustained usage
discounts are, I think,
one of the best features
of Compute Engine when
compared to Amazon's
EC2, because you
don't have to do anything to get
the first level of discounts.
Just the fact that you're
using Compute Engine
throughout the month
means that you'll
get automatic
discounts if you use it
for a certain period of time.
This is in comparison to
Amazon's reserved instances,
which are certainly
very flexible,
but they're so complicated
in figuring out
how many you need to buy,
for which instance types
and in different regions.
And so with the sustained
usage discounts,
they just apply automatically
and you get a discount
as you continue to
use the Compute Engine
instance throughout the month.
That's really good for usage
that you might not be expecting
or is part of a new
application, and not
something that you are
just learning about.
But once you know what your
workload is going to be
and you've got static
workloads or workloads that you
can predict into
the future, then you
can buy the committed usage
discounts, which gives you
even more of a discount.
You don't have to
pay anything up front
but you do get a commitment.
It's basically contracting for a
period of time, a year or three
years, I think it is.
YURI: So thank you
very much for that.
I wanted to give some of
the folks on our live chat
to get their questions answered.
And now might be a good time
to ask their first question.
You've already talked
about some of the things
you're using in GCP.
Obviously, you're running
on Compute Engine.
Big Table is obviously a big
part of the architecture.
And you've already
told us that you're
using BigQuery for analysis.
I realize it may be
somewhat difficult to do
without a visual aid,
but I'm wondering
if you can give us a
short summary of what
does your architecture
on GCP look like
and what products in GCP
are you really using?
DAVID MYTTON: Yeah, absolutely.
So the first product that
we started using, as I said,
was Big Table.
And when we moved that use
case over, we were at the point
where we needed to rewrite
that project anyway.
So we were lucky to be able to
spend the time to completely
rewrite that from scratch
to use Container Engine,
to have it completely
containerized,
and to use all of the core
Google products around it.
But with the other parts of the
application that we moved over,
we decided we wanted to get onto
Google as quickly as we could,
and so we just
lifted them directly
from VMs or the
bare metal servers
and they run completely onto
Compute Engine instances.
So for many of the
systems that we have,
we're not getting the full
advantage of Google Cloud,
in the sense we're not
using all of the products
that we might use.
But that's the direction
that we're going.
And so the direct lift from
the VMs and the bare metal
over to the Compute
Engine instances
was aided because
the architectures
is a microservices setup.
So we have probably 15 or
20 or so different services
internally within
Server Density that
manage different areas
of the application.
And these are all made available
internally through an HTTP API.
And our web UI for
customers is built
on top of that with an
authentication layer,
as is our public API.
So as a Server Density customer,
if you are using our API,
you're using the same API
that our engineers are
using internally to manage
the different aspects
of your account.
So things like alert
configurations, user profiles,
the inventory in your account
for the different resources
you're monitoring, these
are all based around APIs.
And the architecture
itself is microservices,
and the code is mostly Python.
So we have load balances, the
Google load balance products
internally.
We also use NGINX in a
couple of different locations
and where we're running
our own load balances.
But our goal is to
move everything over
to Google services so that we
can containerize everything
and also take advantage
of things like the Pub/Sub
product, which will be
replace-- our plan is to replace
the Kafka and Storm
setup we have,
so when alert
payloads come in, they
get processed through Kafka
as the queueing system.
And then we have a number
of different engines
which determine whether an
alert should be triggered
and where the data will go.
So part of it will go into
the alert engine, part of it
will go into Big Table to be
stored for long-term storage.
And so the plan is to
replace Kafka with Pub/Sub
at some point, so that we
get the full managed service
element of it.
And so the architecture
is fairly sophisticated.
YURI: Thank you very much.
And that actually,
I think, starts
to answer one of
the other questions
that we have on the line here,
which is, how should folks
think about migrating to GCP?
Should they be, like
you said, trying
to get to Google
as fast as possible
by simply migrating their
VMs to Compute Engine?
Should they be
re-architecting and re-writing
their applications or
just containerizing them?
And it sounds like the path you
chose is some of all of that,
right?
Some things you
migrated as they were.
Some things you ended
up rewriting or at least
containerizing.
Based on your
experience with that,
do you think you would
do anything differently
if you were to do it again?
Any kind of lessons learned
from some of those choices?
DAVID MYTTON: I think the
underlying principle should
be to keep it as
simple as possible.
Because doing a migration to
a new provider is a big task,
and it's going to
take a lot of time.
And you want to have as few
moving parts as possible.
So our initial workload
was to rewrite and deploy
onto Big Table, using all of
the Google products around that.
But we had no time constraints.
Because this was the first
thing, we were testing it out.
And we connected Google up
to our previous environment
using a secure VPN.
And that has its overheads.
There's obviously
a bandwidth limit.
There's a cost to sending
data over the internet.
Although it's
encrypted, you still
have to pay for all
the data transfer.
And there is a small
performance hit because you're
moving data over the internet.
But really, moving
the resources should
be done as quickly
as you possibly can,
because of the
complexity of doing it.
And if you're going to rewrite
the entire architecture
at the same time, you're
going to end up changing
so many different things.
It's probably going
to cause problems.
YURI: Excellent.
Thank you so much.
And then I'll ask you one
last question, which I
know may not be an easy answer.
Perhaps you answered
this at the beginning.
But if you were to
summarize your decision
to choose GCP over
AWS, what would
you say were the top
two or three things that
swayed your decision?
And also, I would love
to hear, personally,
if there was anything
that actually made
that decision
difficult, if there were
some advantages that AWS
had that you essentially
had to trade off in
order to take advantage
of the benefits of GCP.
DAVID MYTTON: So I'll
start with the second bit,
because I think it's probably
the most obvious one, which is
that AWS is the biggest Cloud.
And so there are more
people who know about AWS.
There's more blog posts.
There's more resources.
They have just a
bigger ecosystem.
And that can make a
difficult decision
to go with what I think is
actually a better technology
choice.
Because although Google doesn't
have as many products, when
it comes to comparing the
portfolios against AWS,
the products that
are there, I think,
are much better designed
and much better implemented.
Just the documentation
is better.
The APIs are better.
The interface is better.
It's much more consistent.
And although some
features might be missing,
the ones that are there are the
ones you actually need to use.
And they just work as
you'd expect it to.
And it's clearly been designed
from the beginning, which
everything, I suppose,
has iterations.
And AWS has the
advantage and also
disadvantage of having been
around for a very long time.
So they've got
legacy things that
don't work quite so consistently
or aren't quite as well
designed, just because
they've been built on later.
Whereas GCP has the advantage
of all of Google's experience
being able to go into it
from the beginning as a newer
product.
I think the thing that probably
stood out the most for us
and where we had to make
changes after migrating
was around the networking
and the cost of that.
We moved from an
environment where
we didn't have to pay for any
internal networking at all,
all the traffic was completely
free across all of the data
centers that we had.
And when you move to
the Cloud, whether it's
Google or any other
Cloud provider,
they all charge for all
of the network usage
outside of a single zone.
And for the best
practices, you have
to deploy across multiple zones.
And you need to do that
just to get the redundancy
and reliability, and ideally
across multiple regions.
But it's really
expensive to do that,
particularly if you have noisy
services internally that you
don't control, so something
like Kafka and sending the data
around different clusters.
Or even database replication
can be very noisy.
And you have no real
control over that.
And it can be a hidden cost
that you might not be expecting.
NICK ORLOVE: That makes sense.
And I know that there's
quite a few papers out there
that Google's published, that
the industry has published
on trying to rationalize
building for best practices,
building for high
availability versus building
for cost optimization.
So it absolutely makes sense.
So I know that we're
right around the mark.
So maybe if I can ask
one last question,
maybe the $1,000 question is did
you find that it was worth it?
Are you glad that
you moved over?
Any last thoughts that you
want to share on that subject?
DAVID MYTTON: Yeah, absolutely.
We are very happy
now that we've moved
onto modern infrastructure.
And we can let Google
deal with some things that
just have no
additional value for us
as a competitive differentiator.
So scaling the time
series database,
we don't have to deal
with that anymore.
Our overall cost has been
reduced by almost 50%.
And that's because
we've been able
to get significant efficiencies
from using a managed service as
opposed to having really
beefy hardware, which
might have been fun to
say you've got hundreds
and thousands of gigabytes
and terabytes of SSD,
but actually wasn't delivering
enough value for the business.
We can also say we're on
modern infrastructure that
is carbon neutral and moving
towards being completely
renewable, which is great
for us as a business.
But our engineers love
being in an environment that
has modern APIs and modern
systems and features.
And so it's definitely
been worth it.
And yeah, I'd highly
recommend the move.
NICK ORLOVE: Cool.
Well, thank you very much
for all the feedback.
And actually, I do
have one more question.
Since you are our
customer, since you
guys at Server Density are
having some amazing products
that are helping our
customers, helping us,
et cetera, anything in 2018
that we can look forward to
from a Server
Density perspective?
Anything cool coming
down the road?
DAVID MYTTON: So the main
thing is the integrations
that we have with
various services
that people are running.
So whether that's software,
databases, web servers,
anything that you're running
in your infrastructure,
and also the Cloud providers
that you might be using,
we're building significantly
better integrations
that we can pull in data
from any of your environments
and help you visualize
and monitor it,
and making sure that that is
visualized in interesting ways.
Graphs are cool.
But there are other ways
to get the information out
of your infrastructure
about what's
going on, where the problems
are, and how to optimize it.
So that's what we're building.
NICK ORLOVE: Cool.
That's fantastic.
Well, David, I
feel like we could
talk to you for so much longer.
I just love all the
insights that you have.
You've walked this path before.
So thank you very much for
spending the time, especially
since it's after hours
in the UK right now.
But to everyone else
who's listening,
thank you for watching.
Please remember to rate, thumbs
up, thumbs down, subscribe.
Yeah, hopefully thumbs up.
And we will see you next time.
So, awesome.
Thank you so much, David.
Thank you, Yuri.
YURI: Thanks for having me.
NICK ORLOVE: And thank
you everyone out there.
DAVID MYTTON: Thank you.
NICK ORLOVE: See you later.